we have some breaking news just coming
into us some British Airways has been
fined 1.1 million dollars over delayed
refunds now this refers back to during
the covid-19 pandemic it's the U.S
transportation department that is
finding British Airways they're finding
them 1.1 million dollars for failing to
provide timely refunds to passengers for
flights to and from the U.S presumably
for the disruption and the the fact that
passengers couldn't take many of those
flights in fact it says that since March
2020 the U.S transportation department
received more than 1200 that's 1 200
complaints alleging British Airways
failed to provide timely refunds British
Airways which is owned by iag actually
disputed those allegations but they are
being fined um U.S Department of
Transportation says it's crediting
British Airways 550 000 towards the
penalty but because the airline in 2020
and 2021 issued more than 40 million
dollars in refunds to customers with
non-refundable tickets